based on the totality of scientific  evidence available  due to the benefits of the pfizer  biontec  covid19 vaccine outweigh its risks  for use in individuals 16 years of age  and older and that concludes  the vote so we do have a favorable vote  i just wanted to thank the committee  for voting on this very complex topic i  wanted to thank the committee  for their discussion and their  suggestions we very much appreciate  the their input on this very important  topic  and we will take what we've heard today  into consideration  when deciding on not only the eoa  issuance here but also you know how to  move on  uh in the development of and licensure  of this product thank you so much